hello hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome back to huniepop
now I've been practicing in the
background and as you can see by my
honey score I've been flirting with the
girls non-stop off-screen for days and
days on end I really have nothing else
to do with my time and I'm a sad sack
but I'm very comfortable I get my stop
I'm sure I have been playing in the
background and I do know more about the
game and Susie of kitty-kat gaming and
the grumps has given me a little cheat
sheets here of all the different
characters here and I've actually been
flirting with many of these girls and I
kind of know a little bit about them now
and I decided Audrey don't ask me why I
think she still there isn't that she's
such a mega [ __ ] I think that I think
that's actually hilarious so what I'm
gonna do is I'm going to first use all
of my honey points to upgrade my stuff
here and this particular girl likes
flirtation and not romance so I'm gonna
go for flirtation a lot gonna bump up
sexuality talent little bit romance
passion Christmas look sensitivity if
you know what I mean maybe Babu Babu
yeah okay so now that I'm fully upgraded
and I used a lot of points and I had to
farm for a long time to be able to do
this I'm gonna go on the state but
before we do that I also got a present
because another thing that I need to do
is I need oh oh that's so cute
oh that's so cute okay so now I have
another date gift a stuffed penguin
which is awesome also I need to check to
make sure yes I need to buy this bag of
goldfish I would never get my hopes up
with you pretty lady
who happens to be a giant Meggie [ __ ]
named Audrey bellerose have a full TT
the buzzer was inside your own heart
okay so now that I know about this game
I've actually had practiced with the
getting good combos on this one so I'm
gonna be much more better written than
that this game that I lose I need to get
some more sentiment I'm gonna do dad
it can't be it can't be balls enough
everything about everything that I'm
doing look at all that sentiment
I didn't get much better and when you
upgrade all your points these are worth
more as you're playing through this game
and because they started it up pretty
well you do want to get your passion
level up early on in the also you want
try to get calm bruised I'm gonna be
able to have combos though there's also
specific things that these girls like in
terms of what their personality actually
reflects like she likes I believe the
red ones more than anything which
started this off with a bang anyway
girls you slam together your candy
pieces until it loads into joy and
affection and then you go on the date of
your life and you meet the mega [ __ ] of
your life soul soul mega [ __ ] your soul
mate too [ __ ] your [ __ ] mate your soul
[ __ ] anyway so that's how you flirt
good and then when you've got more
points with your hoo knees in your money
then you buy them gifts and then your be
able to get more Hootie's with them and
then hurry up the storm until you get to
the place where you need to get with the
girl
what if I asked her I have no idea
that's all you okay you can still knock
a [ __ ] out okay why Alberti people say
I look younger I know why you look like
a [ __ ] anyone what else you do you also
buy him oh she likes cigarettes she is a
lovely person when you buy him unique
gifts I'm still kind of a loser for
talking to you not you you okay so when
you buy them a unique gift you actually
get more hooni overall that's talk no my
stupid think it's not pronounced who do
you go to whatever
what's your last name Belle Rose
whatever cost no I came to Thunder are
you okay so there's another thing that I
need to do that I wanted to show you but
I can't show you because none of these
people are where I want them to be I
like Lola those are loves cool fine
whatever we only went on a magical date
filled with love and adventure I'll just
be on my way
hello anyway so how you doing good I'm
gonna buy you a unique gift I'm gonna
buy you the wing pin also there are
symbols right by the gifts so I don't
know why I know you wanna be a pilot and
you are a stewardess right now so I
forget what I've asked you I've asked
you pretty much every Lola
23rd I won't forget I promise me rap
let's go one day let's go a date you and
me I want to date you good I apologize I
don't mean to skip over what they're
saying it's just that I've turtle onto
this boat before I've heard a lot of
rejection in my life and I don't need
more of a jab me if I start to doze off
Sam innuendo I take as if that's what
they all say right the beat so I'm a
keeper oh I'm a keeper oh that means so
much in my heart you're so much nicer
than the mega [ __ ]
all right so also Lola's slip-and-slide
outfit
you mean her bikini which is weirdly not
very covering of her body okay so also
when you're playing you get pictures
from the people that you're dating so
hello
smoking rate 40 push-ups finally get
whoa were you oh you're the fitness lady
that's right so you get a bunch of
pictures and you can actually look at
the pictures when you got them and you
collect these pictures in your weird
gallery of all the people that you know
hello too hot for teacher
then Bailey who's adorable I mean a lot
of these girls like they all represent a
certain archetype of girl or something
like that or I don't really know what
I'm talking about
and also there's let me see if wait
Donna would Park that's where I need God
I think I need to go to the park this is
actually something that I learned when I
was reading up about the game you can
get because there's certain characters
that you can unlock if you do certain
things and this is one of those things
so
Wow expect to run into anybody here so
there's a way to like
oh there we go
there we go AHA here boom done okay so
now that happened now
25th of June that's close to mine mine's
the 28th the two we're destined for each
other
calm down when somebody makes me angry
something I try to relax and remember
that nobody's perfect I know we do
except for me because I'm priming except
for you cuz you're perfect I guess I
could grace her with my presence oh yes
I could go on a day when yo it was a job
I brought a lot of eggplant I'm sorry I
know that maybe I planned for your face
lady I guess there's nothing to satisfy
you fine oh I forgot there's little
stars right babe that's right okay so I
need
belly you're 511 because you're one inch
short then yes five
one inch shy six foot that's right 511 I
do care if that's an indication who
cares about who wanna go on a date with
you you're cute you're adorable
yeah you're so full of fun like joy but
I don't mind whatever we do just keep me
away from all the junk food I'll do my
best unless I'm shoving it right in your
face okay to say thank you lady
gosh here we go here we go big combo
because I farmed up a lot of honey
points oh I sure did
gosh you're so great oh you're so cute
okay boy now I probably have to go talk
to the mega [ __ ] again
all right so apparently if I leave here
do I have to come back to get back all
right rest easy
I shall you too lady oh oh
bestiality I don't want that achievement
no okay well we're gonna end this on
this episode before it gets any weirder
thank you all so much for watching hope
you're enjoying it so far see you next
one I guess